diese woche beschlossen deutschland
kriegt einen mindestlohn für azubis sehr
gute idee denn der handwerker an sich
ist bei uns ja inzwischen so was wie
eine bedrohte art muss man so sagen ja
fachkräfte und handwerker mangel sind
die bremse für unsere wirtschaft auch
öffentliche bauprojekte kommen deswegen
immer schleppender voran das ist ein
riesenproblem damit ein riesenproblem
und während die baupreise hier durch die
decke gehen sucht die branche
verzweifelt frisches fleisch nachwuchs
teilweise mit großen kreativen einsatz
wie hier die berühmte glaserei sterz ich
habe zwei ausbildungsplätze zu vergeben
wenn du auch gerne sachen kaputt macht
da kommt so glaserei sterz hier ist
sogar der meister alles falsch wir
brauchen in deutschland glaser mal da
waren wir brauchen maurer wir brauchen
tischler ich sage es muss wieder cool
sein hier elektriker zu werden
es muss wieder cool sein ja wenn man
nach zählt aktuell fehlen mindestens
150000 fachkräfte im deutschen handwerk
das ist dramatisch vor vielen schulen
parken schon handwerker um
vorbeikommende oberstufenschüler
anzuwerben entschuldigung hat man mal
eben helfen
[Applaus]
wieder aufgewacht ist die arme sau auf
der baustelle meine damen und herren
warum will keiner mehr eine lehre machen
gibt verschiedene theorien vielleicht
auch weil gesellschaft und
bildungspolitik jahre lang wollten dass
hier praktisch jeder abitur macht jedes
jahr verbessert sich in deutschland der
abischnitt was ja bedeuten würde
übersetzt dass unsere kinder immer
genialer werden mein privater eindruck
ist ein anderer
und auch dieser friseur ist irgendwie
enttäuscht was unheimlich auffällt dass
viele junge leute überhaupt kein spiel
hat das geht also morgens schon los mit
guten morgen oder sich abzumelden oder
was kann ich machen
der letzte eine praktikantin der von der
schule
die warf er gar nichts zu gebrauchen
deswegen toller satz in
praktikumszeugnis die larissa war zu gar
nichts zu gebrauchen
im malerbetrieb würde man von einer
echten pinsel begabung springen in den
kommenden jahren suchen rund 200.000
handwerksbetriebe ein nachfolger bei der
chef in rente geht diese blöde
akademisierung welle dieser
akademisierung soir
da muss man endlich gegensteuern hier
neuer spot jedes jahr im mai wird
deutschland überrollt von über 400.000
völlig nutzlosen klugscheißer
abiturienten und dann fluten die pfeifen
unsere hörsäle kein mensch braucht noch
einen slawistik bachelor
diese frau hat einen doktor in physik
und schlägt sich trotzdem gerade so
durch
und was machst du lineare algebra zum
kotzen geh arbeiten wir sagen dübeln
stadt grübeln eine aktion des deutschen
handwerks
[Musik]
eingeflossen
[Applaus]
für sich
aber die stadt im moment der ehrlichkeit
in wirklichkeit haben ja leute wie ich
die irgendwelche lover fächer studiert
haben einfach nur angst dass uns bald
keiner mehr das dach repariert deswegen
sage ich zu den kindern anderer leute
macht gefälligst eine lehre
wieso will denn hier keiner der klempner
werden in einen klempner das war doch
immer ein spannender beruf ich verstehe
es nicht
man kann halt keinen zwingen
du kannst keinen zwingen fachkräfte aus
dem ausland könnten die lösung sein
sagen manche aber die gehen
offensichtlich auch lieber woanders hin
in einer aktuellen studie rangiert
deutschland nach der schweiz singapur
den usa und den skandinavischen ländern
nur auf platz 14
die hauptgründe sind sprachbarrieren und
das gefühl in deutschland nicht wirklich
willkommen zu sein
die fühlen sich nicht wirklich
willkommen
warum nicht
das könnte ein grund sein grüße blauen
heutzutage noch einen handwerker termin
zu kriegen ist jedenfalls wirklich sowas
wie ein sechser im lotto wenn das so
weitergeht prophezeit sind handwerker
bald der neue adel martin klempnow zum
beispiel martin klempnow ist einer der
begehrtesten männer deutschland vielmehr
ist installateur das ehepaar kirche die
werden bestimmt total happy sein mich zu
sehen naja ist ja auch kein spaß und
zwei jahre auf der baustelle ohne
fließend wasser zu hause
wie die tiere aktuell wartete kunde im
baugewerbe im schnitt 14,5 wochen auf
einen termin da ist die ankunft eines
echten handwerkers natürlich ein
emotionaler moment
diesmal nahmen ihre mietwohnung vor zwei
jahren gekündigt weil ich ihnen gesagt
habe dass wir bald fertig sind
da steckst du nicht drin sagt wie's geht
auf wasser obwohl vielleicht ein
bisschen käse fondue aber nicht recht
wenn es keine umstände macht lebt das
thema ausbildung sehr ernst schon irland
die drei wichtigsten handwerker setzte
daniela schreiber auf nach fest kommt ab
war dies gar nicht unser gewerken wir
haben halt genauso gemacht wie sie sich
das gewünscht haben das nicht
neu gemacht werden dann wird es aber
sehr teuer wie judo schlicht
vorgearbeitet und das haben wir immer so
gemacht
normalerweise müsste doch haben wir noch
nie so gemacht ganz ganz wichtig warum
sie dafür unbedingt eine rechnung
das ehepaar kirchhoff kann die spannung
kaum noch ertragen wird martin klempnow
heute wirklich die toilette anschließen
im prinzip aber ich habe meinen 19 mal
gar nicht dabei
die neben hoher entschuldigung heißt
übersetzt ich komme es in zwei jahren
wieder
[Musik]
während gehabt im café rechnen konnte
tut mir ja auch menschlich seite
irgendwie aber ich kann mich auch nicht
verteilen
[Musik]
handwerker das gute gefühl gebraucht zu
werden
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok
[Musik]
wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße